so today I'm here to talk to you about
babies and their understanding the world
specifically their understanding of
dangerous situations but first in case
you haven't interacted with a baby
recently here are some clips of what we
call typical one-year-old Behavior well
uh from this you might think that babies
don't understand anything about
dangerous situations or maybe they don't
understand anything about anything but
today I'm going to tell you five
surprising things that I learned while I
did this work the first surprise is that
babies are really willing to do
dangerous things so these are videos
captured in the lab and the finding from
this work is that one-year-old babies
are perfectly willing to walk off the
edge of these steep drop offs without
even thinking
twice and in fact they need months of
experience learning to walk before they
start to show any signs of fear in these
situations so that was work completed
before I started my PhD and so I looked
at these findings and I thought really
is it really true that babies are
oblivious to danger or could we figure
out another way to study this question
so the history of Developmental
Psychology tells us that if we study
babies by measuring complex behaviors we
might miss out on Hidden Truths about
their minds so what should we do instead
well another way is we can ask them what
they think when other people are put
into the same situation from the first
months of life babies have expectations
about the world that objects are solid
and don't float in midair that people
have intentions and goals and their
expectations are often clearest when
they themselves are looking at the
events rather than participating in them
so that's going to be surprise number
two if you test babies at the same age
as I just showed you in the second way
you see a completely different pattern
of
results so um here is an example of one
of our stimuli and uh babies are going
to see someone else this red guy in the
middle face a choice to jump left or
jump right now intuitively you can
recognize that one of these choices is
more dangerous than the other falling in
the ditch on the left would be a lot
worse so all else being equal maybe this
red guy is going to go right and the
question for babies was can they make
that distinction and do they have that
same expectation so here we're measuring
how long babies look at each of these
outcomes and the simple logic of this
measure is that babies and indeed people
of all ages tend to pay more attention
to what's surprising in this when the
red guide does the more dangerous
thing so here's what we found I'm
plotting looking time on seconds on the
vertical axis and in red is the average
looking when babies saw the more
dangerous choice in green and the safer
choice in Pink So indeed they look
longer when someone chooses a dangerous
thing over a safer thing but in contrast
the very same babies responded
completely differently when they saw
these very very similar control videos
with the same obstacles it except this
time there are no characters in the
scene so there's no danger at all and
this suggests is that they're not
responding to the obstacles themselves
and they're actually really responding
to the danger that's imposed by the
obstacles so that's the second surprise
babies do understand something about
dangerous situations but remember based
on their own choices this is shocking we
wouldn't expect a one-year-old to care
about the distinction between a deep
versus a shallow drop at all but
measured in this way babies are making
exactly that distinction when someone
else faces the same
choice so surprise number three is that
this finding generalizes regardless of
whether babies are tested in stab uh in
sterile lab environments like this an
empty room with nothing else but our
videos to look at and cluttered home
environments so in the middle of this
work Co hit and developmental
psychologists everywhere scrambled to
figure out whether data collection was
even possible if you asked me I would
have predicted definitely not there's a
reason that we conduct studies in the
lab our movies can be projected to these
huge screens we can minimize distraction
we can get highly precise uh high
definition videos of where the babies
are looking but we figured we had to try
so after a long process of figuring out
exactly how to do this we ended up
calling video calling families at home
and they play the same movies for babies
on their laptop screens and we measure
their looking behaviors just like before
so let's just pause and take stock of
all the differences between these two
setups in many ways this was doomed to
fail I certainly thought it was going to
fail but that's not what
happened so on the left are the results
I just showed you with babies tested in
the lab and on the right is the same
experiment we repeated in a new group of
babies tested at home and as you can see
the main results look remarkably
similar so that was surprise number
three this finding is similar regardless
of whether babies are tested in the lab
or at home so I just want to pause and
state how non-trivial and actually
really groundbreaking this was for my
field my prediction that we cannot study
babies using these measures at home
wasn't true at all and during this
process we learned not only that these
studies can work at all but that they
can actually work really well and at the
end of the day this process was just
easier and faster for
everyone so we ended up being able to
collect video data faster than ever
before which actually required us to
engineer two new tools for processing
the data so here I'm showing you a tool
we built that can find a baby's face
given a a webcam of their uh of their
study and detect where they're looking
as good as a human can that is robust
even for these very fuzzy low uh
lowquality webcam videos so this whole
experience was amazing uh for our team
and for me this experience is its own
achievement it took families and
scientists working together to figure
out how to study baby Minds in a
changing
world so that was surprise number four
the pandemic rather than delaying and
maybe ending the work in my field
actually accelerated it I never would
have tried online research had Co not
not happen but now that we've tried it
it's vastly expanded the reach of our
work these tools enable us to study
babies anywhere in the world with an
internet connection it lets us work with
families of varying demographics and it
lets us more easily access clinical
populations that can be harder to reach
so the last surprise surprise number
five all along I've been telling you
that babies look longer when someone
chooses a dangerous action or are
willing to do really dangerous things
when I probably should have said on
average on average the baby we tested
look longer at X on average babies are
willing to do y so to illustrate this
point here are the same graphs I showed
you before but hidden in these graphs
and in all the data sets from my field
are vast individual differences so now
I've added back all the raw data that
you didn't see before now each pair of
points is a baby and as you can see
there's striking variability between
babies that average out to an effect now
to be clear I don't think this
undermines the conclusion of the work
the key prediction is that at home and
in the lab babies are sensitive to
something about these dangerous
situations but one remaining puzzle from
my field is what these individual
differences
mean so one answer is that's just
measurement noise we're studying babies
they can't follow directions they have
short attention spans they're free to
basically look as long as they want so
maybe these differences don't mean
anything it's just random noise a second
answer is that part of these differences
is driven by external factors so maybe
for our online sample the babies who
showed the biggest effects had the
biggest screens to look at or maybe the
clearest internet
connections and the third answer maybe
the one that's the most interesting is
that these differences reflect something
that's true about the actual differences
between these babies so for example
suppose that we put babies from this
looking Time study in the physical
situations that I showed you from the
beginning of the talk remember there are
individual differences in those
experiments too so a question could be
would the babies who show the strongest
effects here be the ones who also are
more likely to be afraid and avoid doing
the dangerous things themselves and
similarly are the babies who do not show
an effect here the ones that are willing
to kind of boldly uh plunge into the
abyss so to be clear I I don't know
which one of these answers is right but
I think it's important to show this
variability in our papers and to study
them so I think that these challenges
are actually tractable in part because
of the tools that were delivered by the
pandemic so stay tuned and maybe I'll
have an answer for you uh next time we
see each
other so that's the last surprise
certainly a surprise for me who started
out looking at bar plots of average
behaviors and assuming that most babies
behave the same instead there's
variability in human development on just
about any measure we can make on just
about any topic we can study from
physical understanding to language
learning and making sense of these
individual differences telling apart the
signal from the noise continues to be a
challenge and an opportunity for my
field
so the next time you look into the eyes
of a baby know that there's way more
going on in their minds and brains than
you might think so zooming out to the
big picture let's think about what these
findings tell us about the origins of
the mind so to me these findings and
many other findings from our field tell
us that babies have abstract knowledge
about the social and the physical world
they can perceive and reason about
events they've never seen before like
these stimuli they can represent not
only uh what happened but what could
happen next or maybe what could have
happened but didn't
and early in development babies are
learning to solve these two really
really hard problems the first problem
of connecting other people's actions to
their physical situations and hidden
mental States and also the second hard
problem of figuring out how to act in
the world given what they know so of
course that's both an interpretation and
a hypothesis we have a lot to learn
about these profoundly intelligent minds
and actually the magic of that process
reminds me a lot of a
one-year-old falling over having a long
look at the obstacles before us and then
taking a big leap thank
[Applause]
you